[Music]
abigail is with us in rapid city south
dakota hi abigail what's up
hi it might be a little windy where i am
i am
currently working and i'm outside but
my boyfriend and i are looking to move
in together and we can't agree on
whether to
rent an apartment or buy a house
together
buying house together without being
married just doesn't seem right to me
and i'm looking for some
advice well i think you're definitely on
the right track with that i would not
recommend buying a house with somebody
you're not married to that can open up
so many doors to
complications
what's your kind of timeline for wanting
to make a move
um within
three to six months
okay
how old are you guys
um we're 20 and 22.
20 and 22.
okay
if you're willing to talk about buying a
house and you're willing to move in
together why aren't you willing to get
married
um we're young yet
we are high school sweethearts young
people get married all the time
yeah i know and we've been talking about
i think we'll probably get married
within a year or two
or we're i'm calling because we're going
to have a serious conversation this
weekend because
i want to get forward with our
our plan of when we're going to get
married and how much the wedding should
be possibly so
yeah
okay so
um
you you called asking advice about the
house and about the whole situation i'm
gonna give you more than you asked for
okay okay
there was a the brookings institute did
a study
that said in america if you do three
things
your probability to avoid poverty
is statistically
astronomical in other words the
likelihood of being in poverty if you
avoid these three things
is very very high
marry before you have a kid
have your first child after age 20
and get married before you live together
that's a statistical analysis
okay
and
um the chances of divorce for people
that live together before they get
married are four times higher
than people who get married before
living together
statistical evidence
interesting
so yeah if uh
my youngest is 30
uh when they were
in their 20s if we had been having this
conversation i would say why do you
think you can beat the odds
there must be some reason behind all of
this
there must be some reason behind all
this so if bubba is willing to sleep
with you and buy a house with you he
should be willing to marry you
that's my dad talking
all right okay see i told you it was
getting more than you looked for
[Laughter]
and you know what abigail it's not
because i'm trying to make you mad it's
because i care about you kiddo and i
want you to win and you called here
looking out a win
yep i did so thank you so don't buy a
house for god's sakes or somebody you're
not married to
because when you break up it's very very
difficult when somebody dies or becomes
disabled it's very very difficult
when someone gets on drugs it's very
very difficult
yeah i thought just like even applying
for a loan when we're not married would
be complicated and i just didn't want to
do that and also
we're just dating i didn't want to have
to deal with the burden of home
ownership yeah so agreed agreed so yeah
rent for sure
and uh but you need to consider these
other statistics as well
uh i kind of got the vibe you're not but
um that's okay it's my job to tell you
it's your job to decide what you're
gonna do you're like a grown-up and
stuff
well and you have a few days to think
about it like really take some time
think about it pray about it evaluate
before you have this conversation get
your own emotions settled because i mean
i think you do have an opportunity to
really
have some of those harder conversations
about where's this relationship going
what's the timeline and it sounds like
you know you guys have a at least the
ability to have the conversation so if
that conversation's happening this
weekend you know just take some time
before it happens to consider what dave
said and see if there's a more wise way
to approach it no
if you're serious enough to make all
these big life decisions then you're
serious enough to make a big life
decision so how old were you when you
got married 23 23 i was 22. yeah so
young people get married all the time
and then you've been married how long
10 years and i got 40.
that's amazing so
you know it works yeah it's an amazing
thing yeah yeah
and um
yeah
there you go well in successful
marriages they're built on those hard
conversations like being willing to have
those hard conversations about yeah
maybe he wants to move in with you or he
wants to wait longer to be married but
then you have to have your boundaries as
well the part of your brain you're using
to make a permanent commitment when you
buy a house
is a pretty similar part of your brain
that you use to make a permanent
commitment when you decide to get
married
because once you're in the house deal i
mean you you got the you got the brand
on your forehead you know i mean you're
there
and you're you're stuck in this deal
and so um
it's a very very similar
set of critical thinking skills that get
you there now i know you're in love and
i know all this and i i know he's very
persuasive
um
well especially if you're buying a house
too like you're signing on a dotted line
for that as well that's pretty
intimidating if you're not married
yeah it's uh
it's hard to get out of either one
marriage or house owning ownership
both are messy so yeah you need to be
really sure what we're doing here with
permanent decisions long-term decisions
this is the ramsey show